you're expecting to get to 102 years old
yes
why not
in 1932 90 years ago the first recorded
birth of a Jewish person in the Las
Vegas Valley Roberta Kane better known
as Bobby just celebrated this birthday
Milestone and from then to now she says
both the Jewish community and Hanukkah
celebrations look much different Ryan
mathey gives us a glimpse of her near
centuries worth of experiences here in
the valley
and the captain nearly A Century Of
Memories on Roberta Bobby Kane's kitchen
counter Friday night was for services
but Saturday night was for gin rummy
she just celebrated her 90th birthday in
November it's 90 years young 90 years 90
years old her parents California
transfers who own two liquor stores on
Fremont Street and Charleston in 1932
she unknowingly made Las Vegas history
as the first Jewish person born in the
valley I admit that I have grown up not
knowing some of the songs or the
Traditions a much different experience
than what Jewish children may experience
today Las Vegas at the time had just
over 5200 people not even 200 of them
she says were Jewish we didn't have a
temple here Temple Beth sholom at 16th
and Oaky until
1946. meaning Hanukkah then mostly
isolated to the homes of the 20 or so
Jewish families in town now the Las
Vegas Valley is home to an estimated a
hundred thousand Jewish people and
though she says Las Vegas was always
accepting to the growing Community it's
not the same Statewide anti-Semitism
incidents have increased 64 percent in
Nevada since 2020 according to the
nonprofit Jew belong but this holiday
the menorah candlelights Globe bright as
Bobby says the community has never been
more united I would say that the Jewish
Community how proud I am of how it has
grown and the wonderful people who are
doing so much
she is celebrating the holidays this
season with her congregation nurtamed
who she calls her family now Ryan asked
the secret to longevity we got to know
the answer here she says a healthy diet
daily exercise and kindness